so uh you're a man of Faith what what
role has Faith played in your life and
your understanding of the world and the
understanding of your own life
and your understanding of uh your work
and how to
your work impacts the world
yeah I think that there's a few
different parts of this that are
relevant
um
there's sort of a philosophical part and
there's a cultural part
and one of the most basic lessons is uh
right at the beginning of Genesis right
it's like God creates the Earth and
creates people and creates people in
God's image and there's the question of
you know what does that mean and all the
only context that you have about God at
that point in the Old Testament is that
he's God has created things so I I
always thought that one of the
interesting lessons from that is that
there's a virtue in creating things
that is like whether it's artistic or
whether you're
building things that are functionally
useful for other people
um
I think that that by itself
is a good
and
I
that kind of drives a lot of how I think
about
morality and my my personal philosophy
around like what what is a good life
right it's I think it's one where you're
helping the people around you and your
being a kind of positive creative force
in the world that is helping to you know
bring new things into the world whether
they're you know amazing other people
kids or
um
or just leading to the creation of
different things that wouldn't have been
possible otherwise and so that's a value
for me that that that matters deeply and
I I just I mean I just love you know
spending time with the kids and seeing
that they sort of you know trying to
impart this value to them and
um yeah it's like nothing makes me
happier than like when I
come home from work and you know I see
like my my daughter's like building
Legos on the table or something it's
like all right I did that when I was a
kid right so many other people were
doing this and like I hope you don't
lose that Spirit where when you you kind
of grow up and you want to just continue
building different things no matter what
it is
um
to me that's a lot of what matters
that's the philosophical piece I think
the cultural piece is just about
community and values and that part part
of things I think has just become a lot
more important to me since I've had kids
um you know it's almost autopilot when
you're a kid
you're in the kind of getting imparted 2
phase of your life but
and and I didn't really think about
religion that much for a while
um when I was in college
you know before I before I had kids and
then I think having kids has this way of
really making you think about what
traditions you want to impart
and um and how you want to celebrate and
like what what balance you want in your
life and
I mean a bunch of the questions that
you've asked and a bunch of the things
that we're talking about
it's just the irony of the curtains
coming down
as we're talking about mortality once
again yeah same as last time this is
just this the universe works we are
definitely living in a simulation but go
ahead um Community tradition and the
values that Faith well I mean religion
is still a lot of the topics that we've
talked about today are around how do you
foreign how do you balance
you know whether it's running a company
or or different responsibilities with
this
how do you how do you kind of balance
that and I I always also just think that
it's very grounding to just
believe that there's something that is
much bigger than you that is guiding
things
that uh amongst other things gives gives
you a bit of humility
um
as you pursue that Spirit of creating
that you spoke to creating Beauty in the
world and as Dostoevsky said Beauty will
save the world